ever wondered what you could watch in
one weekend that would get your energy
up and going something action-packed
well have no fear vinnie tube is here
for today's list we're going to be going
over 10 of my recommendations for this
sort of anime short one core gems that
you may have overlooked somewhere along
the way you ready for some action but
hey before we begin let me ask you this
question ever felt like craving some of
those awesome japanese treats you see on
the internet i'm sure you do and it's an
understatement to say that the japanese
are some of the best in being creative
with their selection of treats this is
where our sponsors of this video tokyo
treat and sakurako monthly japanese
snack subscription boxes come in tokyo
treat and sakurako will help you
experience that really special side of
japanese culture all in the comfort of
your own home by only paying a
subscription fee to either of the boxes
you'll be getting a monthly assortment
of cakes more gt and more delivered
right to your doorstep by the way
sakurago contains more traditional
snacks while tokyo tree caters more on
popular snacks that epitomize the
concept of cool japan with valentine's
day approaching fast it would be a shame
if you didn't have your sweets to give
to your special loved one now wouldn't
it this february they're presenting
special valentine's day boxes a lot of
the snacks in the box are valentine
themed so they're just perfect for the
occasion if you're interested in trying
all of these out don't forget to check
the link and coupon code in the
description box the prices are quite
affordable and you'll get so much of it
that is definitely worth the shot i hope
you'll consider trying these sweets out
now that you've had your share of
sweetness and fluff it's time to get the
ball rolling on some of the most hot
blooded and exciting action anime for
you to binge
right off the bat something sticks out
for katana gathering it's the art style
that carries with itself a design choice
that you don't see in anime every day
set in edo era japan this show can be
summed up as one of the possible
precursors to the modern wuksia tales
that you often see these days it's an
adventure show that's quite wordy and
features some characters who excel in
playing their roles the episodic and
very dialogue-focused nature of the show
may not exactly be for everyone but it
certainly gives us something that was
very different in its era and i say
still holds up to the modern day but
don't be fooled however when it comes to
the action sequences katana god 3
manages to excel thanks to its stylish
flair in the interesting story and world
that it builds through said episodes
it's not flawless but katana gathering
is just that uniquely quirky show that
takes you on an adventure that you won't
forget
let me pull up the credits for sirius
the jaeger pa works something like this
is definitely not the first thing that
comes in my mind whenever i heard pa
works but after watching it i did enjoy
it as i mentioned earlier vampire anime
tend not to always be a kill the
vampires fair like seraph of the end
karin and the recently aired vampire
dies in no time are comedies vampire
night definitely isn't mainly about
killing the vampires sirius the jaeger
falling into the category would set the
viewer up for some expectations right
off the bat overall i think that it
generally sticks to the tropes and story
beats of such a title you have the
expected twist and all but it just works
i find it plain but enjoyable and
passable entertainment it's probably
boosted by the spectacular art quality
actually va works does it again with its
pedigree for visual production
beautifully packaging everything in a
setting an ambiance that feels quite
unique for these let's kill vampires
ensemble shows sirius the jaegers a
pretty cool attempt by pa to branch out
into the genre is it the best in their
catalogue of memorable shows though i
don't think so but it's still a pretty
good popcorn show to binge over a
weekend
next we have another vampire anime
helsing ultimate okay forget what i said
about overlooked as helsing ultimate
back in the days was one of the most
popular action anime of them all you got
the violence the brooding stylish energy
and you've got a rather complete and
satisfying story that clocks in at 10
episodes of ova goodness vampire animes
are a dime a dozen and they come in all
sorts of genres you have the more
comedic ones you have the dramatic
romances and you have the ones with a
modern feel but in terms of intensity
and sheer edgy violence few can come
anywhere close to helsinki ultimate it's
a show that's aged rather well over a
decade into its conclusion and if you
need something so stylishly hot-blooded
helsing ultimate could be your pick this
weekend
so how's this for a recent anime super
crooks is a show that relishes in its
western energy which translates pretty
well in anime format it's got the whole
heroes and villains set up down pat and
it's full of characters who are both
lovable and a joy to follow the
enjoyment gets ramped up with how great
the presentation was compared to my
expectations the voice acting is great
the art's perfect for the mood of the
story and the plot generally flows well
and is easy to consume it feels like
watching one of those hollywood
blockbusters in the realm of say kickass
but in anime form some quick wild fun to
pass time over a weekend if those things
are to your liking super crooks might be
the show to satisfy your cravings
[Music]
honestly speaking it was a bit hard to
sell decadence at first i think mainly
due to its premise monsters forcing
people to bunker up in a dystopian
setting how many of those attack on
titan-like shows have we had already
luckily though decadence has a lot of
good things going for it that sets
itself apart from those shows with
similar premises first off it's an
original anime so when watching i had
almost no expectations the eventual plot
twist did catch me off guard and it was
after then i realized how brilliant some
of them were it started off as a
dystopian fight for a survival thing but
it made good use of its short 12 episode
airtime to evolve the show into
something way beyond that by the time
everything's said and done and at the
end of it all it's a sci-fi show that
transcends the initial action genre and
offers some cool philosophical insights
decadence got overshadowed by the
blockbusters and sequels it aired beside
but this is a true underrated gem that
you just have to watch
soccer
at first glance bna looks like a
superhero show with furries in an urban
fantasy setting after watching it i'd
say that it's got a lot underneath the
surface and it explores a lot of themes
i didn't expect to get tackled political
themes sociological ones conspiracies
it's got a lot more than it initially
suggests but we're not here primarily
for those now are we we're here to have
some action and some fights to get the
energy going and i'm pleased to say that
bna still has those elements in droves
it's rightfully fast paced for a
superpower mystery action and it's
exciting in the sheer potential of where
the adventure can take you it's also got
that trigger thing with revolting
against the system as seen as kill la
kill and guru and lagaan and while i'd
say that those two did that aspect of
the story better bna is no slouch either
trigger rarely disappoints and while bna
probably won't end up at the top of
their greatest hits it is a nice short
show that's well worth your time
now i've often talked about vv and i
still do that's because in the realm of
sci-fi with a bit of those musical
element backdrops i widely consider it
one of the best the anime industry has
to offer especially in the modern era
there's a lot to like about vv the
character development the fluidity of
the art and animation the progression of
the story and of course the fight i
often find it being compared to tact but
let's face it if you have time to go for
either of the two vivi is probably the
more complete show for most people vb
has some themes that strike hard with
how the world is going now it's one of
the very few successful titles to drive
home the themes regarding the dangers of
technology with a strong backdrop of
real world relevant theme amazing sound
direction and fights that are nothing
short of wild and awesome that you just
automatically ignore some of the
sequences that don't make sense vivi is
a surefire hit that's perfect for you to
binge oh and before we continue
subscribe like the video and share the
video with your friends your help would
be really appreciated and let's have a
huge party when we hit that one million
milestone
ah let's go back to old school stuff
with probably my era's poster chart for
edgy psychological titles made infamous
for its gore and stuff that makes your
heart pound for the wrong reasons i'd
say the elfin lead has managed to carve
out quite the legacy for itself it's
quite the polarizing title by combining
those off-putting aspects with an
arguably strong story that couldn't have
worked without them it's got stuff in it
like discrimination and humanity as
themes while putting everything against
the hauntingly memorable soundtrack and
atmosphere does the show have to go
through the lengths of showcasing gore
and nudity to achieve the effect
probably not but with the route it
decided to go i'd say that the anime
team did a pretty damn good job at using
those elements to prop up the feel of
the show an oldie yet a goodie elf and
lead could be your show to watch
i hope you haven't had enough of heroes
yet because this right here is an
awesome show the premise starts out
pretty simple once you've got the meat
of it grandpa has been going through
tough days and as fate would have it he
gets turned into a half machine half
human hero getting granted powers renews
his purpose in life however how does it
all come together when he's set on a
collision course with a similarly
empowered sociopath so the first thing
that'll likely stick out to you is the
uncommon protagonist it's not too often
we see an old man protagonist in anime
and overall i really applaud inuyashiki
for its efforts to stick out despite the
premise that i call simple and common
the show itself has some hidden depth
for its views to uncover when it comes
to themes regarding humanity and
morality is it super unique well not
really but you see the earnest effort
there to connect with the viewers
especially with how the flow of the
story goes don't let the plain premise
dissuade you from watching this amazing
title
now we've reached the 10th entry i'd
like to recommend 91 days several times
i've talked about this title on those
under appreciate or underrated show
lists how can i not want to see such an
excellently crafted show lacking in the
popularity department the sentiments do
still hold true honestly speaking and
while revenge stories are dime a dozen
in anime it's rare to find anything with
an ambiance quite like 91 days it
probably is largely the western classic
literature style approach but you really
feel that this show is something special
in the sea of revenge stories in anime
91 days is for me one of the best in
pushing forth the narrative in a focused
and consistent manner it's quite easy
for revenge stories to forget the
revenge part after quite a while but not
for 91 days it's a crime thriller that
manages to successfully hold the
suspense and theme all the way through
its run it sets itself apart from the
pack with how it shows off the
unglamorous sign of humanity and the
dark recesses of the human heart 91 days
is part of a niche genre but this title
is a gem that anyone with an appetite
for historical suspense with a healthy
dose of violence should watch
how's that for a list if you've got any
other action show recommendations that
you'd like to make provided that they
fall in 12 episodes or less i'd love to
hear about those in the comments section
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video monthly japanese snack
subscription boxes tokyo treat and
sakuraku links are in the description if
the video gave you a good time don't
hesitate to check out the rest of the
channel for other videos and countdown
lists that you might just enjoy you can
also connect with me through instagram
or support the channel through patreon
both which will be linked in the
description box now i had a really good
time making this list and i'm excited to
see what other suggestions that you've
got both for short anime and for future
content you'd like to see i hope you
have a great day see ya
[Music]